so what is the big deal about diabetes
anyway okay so what you have high blood
glucose what damage is that going to do
for your body
well there's really only four tiny
tissues in the body that can be affected
by this high sugar and if you can
actually get rid of these complications
you really wouldn't feel uh that bad
from even having diabetes so it's like
having high blood glucose but without
any major symptoms okay so I'm going to
show you how to get rid of those
complications and then if you want to
get rid of the cause of this problem you
can do that too but today I'm going to
show you five different vitamins that
can get rid of the complications of
diabetes all right so you have this high
blood glucose what four tissues does it
affect well it affects the eyes Okay it
affects
arteries that go through your heart and
other organs it affects the nervous
system including the brain
and it affects the kidney okay other
than that it doesn't really affect
anything else now what can it do to the
eyes well it affects the retina now
that's the main uh nerve tissue that
extends outside the brain and it's
picking up information and springing
into the brain so you can actually see
if you don't get rid of the
complications from diabetes related to
the eye you could go blind okay you can
also have macular degeneration you can
also get cataracts you can even get
glaucoma you can have a lot of problems
with the eye the next problem is the
vascular system the artery okay you have
this layer it's called the endothelial
layer inside the arteries it's highly
susceptible to high blood glucose and so
the complication of diabetes is
plaquing and clots okay which obstructs
blood flow to the heart muscle or it can
actually obstruct blood flow to your
brain so if you have high blood glucose
flowing through your arteries in your
brain that can lead to Dementia or even
Alzheimer's and or Parkinson's or other
types of degenerative brain problems but
also not just the nerves in your brain
also the nerves in the rest of your body
too like the bottom nerves on your feet
you can get what's called peripheral
neuropathy where you have this numbness
or tingling or burning in the bottom of
your feet it can happen in the hands and
the fingertips it also can affect your
digestion it can affect the autonomic
nervous system it can create you know a
lot of issues and the last body tissue
that this high blood glucose affects is
kidney tissue okay high blood glucose
diabetes is the number one cause of
end-stage renal failure okay so it
really destroys the kidney now what is
the kidney kidney is really a filter for
your blood and all this blood and the
sugar goes through it and it just rusts
out the kidney filters now when we say
complications from high sugar
what actually does that mean like for
example when you combine high sugar in
your blood okay your red blood cells you
have hemoglobin that's the protein when
you combine high sugar with that you get
this condition called glycation okay
glycation is the combination of sugar
and protein and it gets all stuck and
sticky and it makes that tissue
um non-functional okay and this is what
A1C is it's basically a number that
represents glycated hemoglobin which is
hemoglobin that is damaged and it's on a
scale so you can tell how bad the
diabetes is it goes in a scale it should
be low but if it's high you can equate
that to a certain amount of sugar
flowing through your bloodstream and so
one reason I like A1C is it gives you an
average of blood sugars for a period of
like three months so it's better than
just a One-Shot assessment because
you're looking at an average and you can
kind of see overall what's happening so
that's what glycation is the common
nation of sugar or carbs that turn into
sugar and protein and you can also get
this from eating foods that combine
sugar with protein and are heated like
for example let's take barbecued ribs
right that would be an example or for
example if you're eating like um I don't
know a hamburger from McDonald's and you
have the bun on it right you have to
there's a there's carb sugar and protein
and then you have a Coke right then you
have fries but see fries have very
little protein it's mainly carbohydrate
and fat so you can also get glycation if
you combine sugar with a fat okay as in
french fries or a donut where you're
deep frying it especially ice cream okay
because you have all the sugar and fat
and there is some protein in there but
you're just getting major glycation when
you consume that so when this glycation
occurs and it builds up it builds up
into something called
advanced
glycation
end products okay and the more of that
that you have kind of stuck in the
tissues the more complications you're
going to have because with that comes a
lot of free radical damage inflammation
and something called oxidative stress
which is just a lot of oxidation and
it's like your body is rusting out and
these tissues are becoming unavailable
to you and so these four tissues the eye
the nerve and brain
the arteries of the heart and other
parts of the body and the kidney are the
tissues that can accumulate more of
these Advanced glycation and products
than other tissues and the acronym is a
g e s like an age so when you think
glycation you can just think you're
going to age very quickly you're going
to get older very quickly because it's
going to make these tissues very old and
damaged now what's interesting about
this there are natural things that can
inhibit this glycation okay so let's say
for example you don't even change your
diet right but you want to get rid of
the complications for diabetes this is
what you should do there actually is
five vitamins you could take to help you
that can act as antioxidants okay and
they're pretty potent the first one and
most important one is
type of B1 vitamin called benphotamine
okay benphotamine has been known to help
clear up these complications especially
with like peripheral neuropathy but also
with other tissues of the eye and I'm
not saying it's going to clear up damage
that you had in the past but it could
definitely reduce the complications and
the ongoing damage that occurs with high
blood glucose so benphotamine that's
that's B1 that's the first one number
two is Vitamin C okay it's a very potent
antioxidant you probably already know
that it's very very good for the inside
of your heart but also in other tissues
as well when you take a vitamin C I
would highly recommend that you get a
food base vitamin C complex not just a
synthetic version of the vitamin C as in
ascorbic acid okay there's a big
difference
the next one is vitamin D vitamin D is a
very important vitamin it's probably one
of the most important vitamins but it
too can act to counter this glycation in
a big way and then the fourth one is
vitamin E vitamin E and I'm in the form
of tocotranols anytime you take vitamin
E I would recommend you take that in a
form that's tocotrino's not the
tocopherols okay not that thecopherols
aren't good tocotrenals just work a lot
better and then when you buy a vitamin
that's a tocotrino I would get the
tocotrino mix or complex but without
these tocopherols because they tend to
compete okay so vitamin E very important
to reduce glycation and the last vitamin
is vitamin B6 B6 can also reduce this
glycation so that is your five vitamins
now there are other things too that can
improve glycation like alpha lipoic acid
okay that's a good one like the
phytonutrient in green tea it's called e
g c g like aged garlic that's another
good one and bitter melon and quercetin
and curcumin and there's many many
others as well if you have a very
nutrient dense salad with micro greens
for example you're going to get a lot of
great things in those plants to help
counter glycation okay because you want
antioxidants now fasting both
intermittent fasting and regular
periodic prolonged fasting okay can
greatly improve this glycation by
causing this condition called autophagy
autophagy is
not a thing it's a condition that occurs
it's like the recycling of old damaged
proteins okay and that's what glycation
really is all about is it damages these
proteins and it becomes unavailable so
when you have autophagy from Fast you
can go in there and clean all that up
this is why you feel so much better and
you have neurological brain improvements
heart improvements immune improvements
blood sugar improvements and the list
goes on and on and on and then exercise
exercise can also reduce glycation okay
so that's all about the complications if
you want to correct the deeper problem
you have to fix the diet okay and the
way to do that is to get on the healthy
version
of the ketogenic diet mixed with
intermittent fasting if you don't have a
plan for that you should definitely
watch this video right here